if you can figure out how to define a
good work-life balance can you like
tell me how to do it
[Music]
hi i'm claudia and i'm a daughter hey
i'm kelsey and i would definitely
consider myself
a bit of an overachiever a daughter
really enjoys
those moments in between tasks i get
things done
but i take my time with it
i don't think i waste a ton of time
because i don't have
a ton of time i have to like schedule
everything in so even like my
social life is highly scheduled i think
a good work-life balance means
you are happy with the way you're
splitting up your time
i only do a work-life balance almost out
of necessity so i don't burn out hi my
name is kevin and i
am a tracker i've been tracking every
single minute of my time for the past 10
years and i know that sounds crazy
but think about it this way if your
money is important enough for you to
track and time is money
then why aren't you tracking your time
as well this week i have convinced a
couple of my coworkers to
track every minute of their time along
with me we are going to be using the
iphone app
now then pro which is a simple time
tracker we're going to be tracking
pretty much
every minute of the day the five
categories are
sleep meals work
personal and projects then within each
category we're going to have a number of
subcategories including commute time
spent with
friends at the end of the week we are
going to get together
take a look at our weeks and see how our
work-life balances
match up to what we thought i'm weirdly
afraid i'm afraid to know that i'm doing
too much
or afraid to know that i'm doing too
little because i feel like i don't know
what could really change
i mean i volunteer for this video
because i do want the data
but i don't really have an interest in
having to categorize
my time all the time my hope is that
claudia and kelsey will get a deeper
sense of how they spend their time
and whether or not they have a good
work-life balance however they define it
so far i'm not in the habit of changing
the app whenever i change tasks there's
like a couple moments where i think i
walked my dog and like i didn't track it
i've just normally like done a task and
not thought about okay this is how i'm
choosing to spend my time every single
thing that i do because every task i'm
inputting this is weird
now we're walking my dog you ready
it was if you could answer me so it's
day one
i don't like it surprise surprise i kept
forgetting to log
things and then just being annoyed at
myself that i had to stop and go back
and grab my phone and re-enter new
information
i just don't think i should be thinking
about
how i spend my time this is it this is
it i don't like it
so what it is i'm going to bed i'm tired
okay it is
5 30 in the morning and the reason i'm
up this early
is so i can work out
meditate shower and
draw for an hour before i head into work
i checked out my stats from yesterday
i slept quite a bit which was nice i
worked on my youtube channel i streamed
a lot for twitch i don't know i guess i
didn't realize that i kind of
essentially
did a whole full day of work extra work
a week on sundays
i don't know i don't know how to process
some of this data
yet day two was much better than
yesterday
um because it was a work day and it was
a lot easier to record things
in the app everything was very
regimented and i was on set so there i
i couldn't mismanage my time because it
wasn't my time it was everybody's time
but it's my
time oh man i can find so many things to
not do
okay today's tuesday end of day three
this morning i drew
for exactly an hour it's really nice
because
um i get all of these things done before
i go to work so the day is already one
and when i get home from work i don't
have the guilt of doing things
and working on projects after i'm tired
at the end of the day
i can't help but judge myself for all of
the decisions that i'm making every day
and i don't know why i'm judgmental of
down time
i consider it wasting a day just sitting
around watching tv
so i was doing really well vlogging at
night i totally forgot last night
i kind of thought i would be forced to
be more productive than i am and instead
i'm just like
making a journal of the way i spend my
time but
not really making any changes i thought
about putting like
cat time maybe i should be giving more
he is a relationship
i've been in my car another 10 or 15
minutes on my phone
so i will record that time accurately
why am i like this so i just had
the most insane stream i think i've ever
had it's almost
eleven at night and i'm finally jumping
off
like when i'm really enjoying how i'm
spending my time i don't regret it at
all which is really
really cool thursday day five yeah i
stayed up late
last night watching netflix it was a
little groggy today but
i know why another fairly typical day
except for the dental appointment this
morning so anyway moving on to day six
friday let's see what happens so i've
slipped up
it's technically been on work mode since
11 a.m yesterday
i don't think i'm learning anything i
think i'm just proving who i am i woke
up
i looked at yesterday's and i
you want to steal this fella here kind
of makes me feel guilty looking at it i
only did like a little bit of my outside
projects today i'm going to be doing a
lot more errands
the week was interesting it was
difficult but also eye-opening it went
all right
i think i was actually a much better
about remembering and dividing my time
than i thought i was going to be i was
like oh this is gonna be disaster i'm
never gonna remember to do this
the process of tracking my time was a
little bit rocky
some days i was a total rock star at it
and there were a couple days that i like
totally couldn't remember to switch
things the nice thing about
tracking is that you get to see all of
your priorities in black and white
and so you can learn some things about
yourself that you didn't necessarily
know
sleep yeah baby the church asleep
work see i worked friends
good relationships personal projects
that's good and then relationship
i would say if those are my top five
priorities i am happy with that you know
what this didn't have
didn't have exercise wow i didn't even
think about that i'll have one thing of
working out here
oh that's not good the biggest amount of
my time was spent
sleeping the next biggest is working
here at buzzfeed next down from that was
just miscellaneous personal tasks i
spent
five percent drawing which is pretty
good
my commute takes up 3.9
of my time i'm sure there's ways that i
can make that more productive
i prioritize eating over working out
which feels backwards
so according to this my priorities is
sleep yeah
and then work is second which i'm not
surprised and then friends is third
relaxing is fourth aka binge watching
game of thrones and
twitch is fifth i think this would be
what i want my priorities to be
this was a week i took two extra days
to myself that i don't normally do i
spend more time getting ready
than walking my own dog i was trying to
be better
so that the percentages would show that
i'm a better dog owner
if i learned anything this week it's
that my life is very boring
it kind of follows the same pattern all
week
not a lot of deviation did it make me
sometimes
question certain ways i was spending
time when like i already knew was
probably a bad idea like wasting time on
my phone
yes everything whether i was working too
much or
relaxing too much was like you're doing
it wrong
at a certain point i realized like i
choose all of these things
every day because i like them i crafted
my life i think a good work-life balance
is
spending an amount of time on your work
that you enjoy
and so that time is like really well
invested and you're getting the most out
of it
it's really interesting to see it on a
graph a good work-life balance in the
end
is something that keeps you motivated
keeps you happy
i think the best work-life balance for
me is just being aware
of how you're spending your time
obviously the people in this video
have fairly uncomplicated lives we're
not married none of us have children
none of us are in school your mileage
may vary but the point is
is that there is no one right way to
spend your time
everybody has different priorities i
think i don't make a priority to relax
or to spend time with friends and that's
something that
i have started implementing more in the
weeks since
i did enjoy the week i will continue to
do it for a while
am i going to be a year longer or a
decade longer
like kevin no i think it was an
interesting change of how i saw
time it's not just like being eaten up
by something else
it was like an allotted amount of money
i could spend how i wanted
it's an important commodity and we
should continually reevaluate how we're
spending it
[Music]
you